okay i'm so excited it's actually
happening this has been a dream of mine
for a very long time
we are kicking off our first pet
adoption week
cats dogs bearded dragons chickens
they're all family to me here's a photo
of me and the kittens that my daughters
and i adopted from the aspca
oh and don't forget right here
representing
um my amazing uh rescue dog named
douglas
he's literally 12 years old and i got
him from the pound in california so
today with the help of our friends at
the american society for the prevention
of cruelty to animals we're introducing
you to pets you can adopt right now
so first from washington dc let's meet
eight-year-old callie
a talkative girl who loves to have her
belly rubbed
callie i feel that now she loves kids
cats and dogs god me too callie we
really do have a lot in common
cali and other available pets in the d.c
metro area go
to thehumanrescuealliance.org
how to adopt so next from lifeline
animal project in atlanta
meet brows he's four years old
he's house trained and he's gentle
and a go-to cuddle bug so anyone in
atlanta who wants to snag this little
snuggler
email adoption at d-clab d-callb
d-cob animal services
and you know what there really is
nothing better than like
i call him dougly douglas his name is
douglas douglas fairbanks barrymore
which seemed like a fitting name for a
pound rescue but he is the douglas
snuggles
and they bring so much to our lives